el 99% de los compuestos aromáticos que
vas a ver en cualquier clase de química
orgánica son derivados del benceno
haider
ven seno ahora los derivados del benceno
no tienen nombres fáciles de deducir por
lo que en este vídeo lo que quiero hacer
es familiarizarte con los nombres de los
derivados del benceno para que si te
encuentras con algún compuesto aromático
sepas muy bien cómo se llama el benceno
es muy sencillo es un anillo de 6
carbonos
con tres enlaces dobles repartidos unos
y 111
esta no es la única configuración del
benceno el benceno tiene una propiedad
que se llama resonancia que vamos a ver
a fondo en un vídeo próximamente pero el
chiste es que el benceno también se
encuentra de esta forma con los dobles
enlaces en estos lugares aunque en
realidad lo que pasa es que cualquier
molécula de benceno en cualquier
instante puede encontrarse en cualquiera
de estas dos configuraciones y
constantemente está cambiando entre esta
configuración y esta otra configuración
por lo que muchas personas lo dibujan de
esta forma con un círculo aquí en medio
para denotar que estos electrones que
están formando estos dobles enlaces
están flotando aquí alrededor
cambiándose de un carbono a otro
constantemente ahora sí tenemos una
molécula de benceno aunque no esté
escrito en cada uno de estos carbonos
tenemos enlazado un átomo de hidrógeno
ahora si cambiamos uno de esos átomos de
hidrógeno por por ejemplo un oro es muy
fácil de deducir igual que en todos
lados esta molécula es un oro benceno
cloro benceno
se no aunque hay bastante sencillo
bastante fácil de deducir y si
tuviéramos por ejemplo en lugar de cloro
y bromo sería simplemente bromo benceno
o si tuviéramos un flúor sería flor o
benceno y así se llaman estos compuestos
ahora sí no sólo tenemos uno de estos
halógenos sino que tenemos dos por
ejemplo si tenemos por aquí un bromo
entonces empezamos la enumeración en
alguno de estos dos de hecho puede ser
cualquiera de estos dos
así es que pues vamos a decir que este
es el carbono número uno y entonces éste
tiene que ser el carbono número dos y lo
que tenemos es 1 bromo bromo 2 cloro 2
cloro
ven
se no bastante sencillo no ahora se pone
más complicado resulta que la y que hace
que es este grupo que le pone el nombre
a los compuestos químicos basándose en
su nombre original pero de una forma
mucho más sistemática y más fácil de
predecir bueno como el benceno es un
compuesto tan arraigado en la química
orgánica este grupo decidió no cambiar
los nombres de los derivados del benceno
y por eso es que son más complicados a
ver digamos que tenemos por aquí un
anillo vencen y ccoo bajada pero que
aquí en lugar de tener un hidrógeno
tenemos un grupo o h entonces esta
molécula se llama fenol
no lo fenol ok aquí ya no tenemos ni una
palabra de benceno ahora si tenemos algo
por aquí muy parecido al final que bueno
en realidad es un phenom pero que además
tiene aquí una molécula de bromo
entonces decimos que esto es un phenom y
empezamos a enumerar por el carbono en
el que está este grupo o h
entonces este es el carbono número uno y
entonces este carbono va a ser el
carbono número 2 y tenemos 12 bromo
fenol si no y supongo que esto es algo
que simplemente vas a tener que
memorizar que el fenol es simplemente un
benceno con este grupo o h por acá y yo
creo que eso es lo más difícil para mí
en la química orgánica cuando estás
hablando con alguien y te dicen el
nombre de una molécula que esperan que
tú sepas exactamente a qué moléculas se
refieren y tú no sabes de qué están
hablando
entonces me imagino que una muy buena
idea es aprender más nombres de
moléculas así es que pues vamos a ver
esta otra molécula que es un benceno
pero por aquí con un grupo metilo esta
molécula se llama tolueno
y si tuviéramos por aquí una molécula de
flúor entonces ya sabemos cómo se llama
esta molécula o sea simplemente tenemos
que enumerar a estos carbonos empezando
por el carbono en el que está el grupo
que como que le está dando el nombre a
esta molécula en este caso esta molécula
se llama tolueno porque tenemos aquí un
grupo metilo entonces este es el carbono
1 el carbono 2 carbono 3 y entonces esta
molécula es 3
flúor o
y oro tolueno a otros compuestos que te
vas a encontrar por ahí los cuales sería
muy bueno que te sepas el nombre aunque
si has visto muchos vídeos de que no
quede me sabes que me choca eso de tener
que memorizar nos cosas me parece que
razonar la situación es una mucha mejor
forma de aprender pero en este caso lo
que tenemos son nombres de moléculas y
además son nombres que no siguen ningún
sistema okay son nombres que se fueron
dando a lo largo del tiempo en distintos
lugares nombres que el sistema upac
aceptó sólo porque eran demasiado
conocidos en toda la comunidad de
química pero que no siguen ninguna regla
ahora otra molécula de la que te tienes
que aprender el nombre digamos que
tenemos aquí un anillo vence mico y que
este anillo vence nico tiene por aquí un
grupo amino
o sea tiene n h 2 esto proviene del
amoniaco que vamos a dibujar por aquí
tenemos un nitrógeno que tiene
es hidrógenos estos tres hidrógenos y un
par de electrones sueltos por aquí ok
este es el amoniaco también conocido
como dash sano y el chiste es que
reemplazamos uno de estos hidrógenos por
un anillo vencen y ccoo y entonces esta
molécula ahora se llama angelina
lina y bueno si tuviéramos por aquí una
molécula de flúor esto se llamaría
simplemente dos flúor o en mi línea o
sea realmente estamos nombrando todos
los compuestos que se derivan de la n
línea de la misma forma en la que hemos
nombrado todas las demás cosas que hemos
nombrado pero bueno vamos a ver otros
dos compuestos derivados del benceno
para que si te los llegas a encontrar
por ahí al menos ya tengas una idea de
cómo se llama y ya no esté tan raro el
nombre digamos que tenemos por aquí un
anillo vencen y ccoo pero que además en
este carbono tiene un grupo car box y lo
aunque entonces tenemos por aquí un
doble enlace un oxígeno y un o h y vamos
a hablar más acerca de los grupos cars
box y los en algún otro momento además
bueno este hidrógeno es muy fácil que se
libere también vamos a hablar de eso en
otro vídeo esta molécula se llama ácido
benzoico ha sido ha sido benzoico ven
sol y ccoo y aquí se puede ver un poco
más en la lógica del nombre de esta
molécula no o sea esta molécula y este
nombre tiene dos componentes una es este
componente del benceno que lo podemos
ver en el nombre aquí benzo y esta otra
componente de que es un ácido
carboxílicos y también lo podemos ver en
el nombre en esta parte de ácido y la
terminación y ceo ahora si se siente que
estos nombres tienen mucha más lógica no
bueno vamos a ver otro de estos
compuestos aromáticos vamos a ponerlo
por aquí tenemos aquí un anillo vencen y
ccoo pero ahora en lugar de tener este
grupo car box y lo ahora vamos a tener
un grupo alde y lo que tenemos por aquí
un doble enlace con un oxígeno y aquí
nada más tenemos un hidrógeno y bueno
aquí implícitamente tenemos un carbono
ok y lo mismo en este grupo car box y lo
no lo dibujé pero
y va a un carbono implícito pero bueno
resulta que el nombre de esta molécula
también es fácil de deducir el nombre de
esta molécula es benz aldehído tenemos
aquí nuestro anillo vencen y ccoo por lo
que su nombre empieza con d
valdés
dense aldehído yo sé que todavía no
hemos visto eso de los aldehídos y de
los ácidos carboxílicos y las aminas y
los vamos a ver con todo detalle más
adelante y vamos a ver cómo reaccionan
con otras moléculas y un montón de cosas
pero por el momento quería que los
vieras quería que conociera su nombre
para que si te encuentras con alguno de
estos compuestos o con el nombre de
algunos de estos compuestos no te
sientas intimidado